and how is that beautiful wife of yours
who I am impressed with we'd be so
impressed with her in in quarantine
Howard I mean she just yeah I mean she's
you know her dad built houses and so
she's like the handyman in the house
the saddest thing now is when something
breaks the kids go to her you know they
don't even they don't even pretend they
don't even think I know where the
batteries are
hey what kind of man I'm the same way
what kind of man am I what kind of man
are you I mean I can't fix anything
and her her brother is also a handy
there was when we first started dating
and and she was moving into my apartment
I remember and by the way I was well
into my 30s playing video games alone in
my apartment and the doorbell rings and
it's her brother in a tool belt and he
said I'm here to fix some things for
Lexi and it was just like well I'm
holding an Xbox controller having a look
at this guy and saying oh yeah yeah I
was gonna yeah if you wanna do it sure I
mean I was gonna get around to it but
you can yeah why don't you get started I
was out with a very masculine friend of
mine and we had a flat tire and he goes
out all right I'll go ahead and change
the tire go let me let me assist and I
go out there and I'm like like like I'm
like like putting my hands on the tire
trying to act like I'm involved I'm like
yeah yeah I didn't even know how to
change a tire
we were just sewn this story of some of
the other night when Alexi and I got a
flat tire we were like away for a
weekend at in in Connecticut no service
on our phone and and so we pull into
this diner and Alexi said I'll go in and
use their phone to call triple-a so she
goes in and she says to the waitress be
on the phone we have a flat tire and she
said oh I'll take triple-a an hour but
my dad's here and he's a mechanic and he
can come out and so this very nice man
goes out with Alexi and clearly the last
thing he expected to see was a man
sitting in the car and I don't even know
they're coming and I'm sitting in the
passenger seat we have a seven pound
Italian Greyhound who has to wear a
sweater and so how emasculating is this
I got a seven pound sweater dog in my
lap and I'm playing Scrabble on my phone
and this guy like taps on the window and
he goes I'm gonna change your tire and I
said okay
and then he said see you have to get out
of the car
you